[Musique]
moi la plus grande star que le monde est
jamais connu afin que je puisse partir
loin très loin de cet endroit
mais n'oubliez pas de vivre votre vie
si seulement il pouvait mourir
pardon
rien
vous pensez vraiment ce que vous avez
dit que vous aimeriez me voir sur cet
écran
je ne peux pas te laisser quitter cette
ferme une fois de plus
[Musique]
j'ai peur qu'il y ait quelque chose qui
cloche vraiment chez moi on dit qu'il
pourrait choisir une vie par village
[Musique]
nous cherchons quelque chose de
différent
que personne d'autre n'avait les gars ça
va l'être un jour
très bien ce que j'ai fait
une chose
terrible affreuse des meurtrières aussi
fermé par le plus de gens possible
et que je suis pas une très bonne
personne
le monde entier
avant la